Liam n is my
shnit but you know who I like as much as
niss as much as n who Bruce
Willie Bruce Willie is
my so it's definitely happening we're
making a
record no I I promise it's going to be a
hit
hey no man thank you what's up my man I
heard about your record deal dog you
going to keep it real all right right
you going to stay true to the roots
right you you're going to let on your
boy your boy Dwayne Dwayne Washington
Ramsey Jun higho yo if it ain't Craig
the man of the yah homie you remember me
I'm Teresa cousin you going to keep it
real yeah definitely going to keep it
real man so
yeah what up what up it's my favorite
Craig I I don't know you man you don't
know me
is that house going to be Craig no I
really don't know you you changed all
right you good you good steak Craig
phone hey young blood my girls take care
of you you take care of me oh all right
all
[Music]
right hello Craig phone it's for you
brother oh thanks man thanks all right
hello
yeah it fell
through it's not
happening damn man n it's all right
thanks
anyway sorry
everybody
damn what what what what what check
yourself before I body piss your damn
skull think you can pull that trigger
before I blow your personality out the
back of your head then go right ahead
and test the hypothesis and see what
happens all right I'm going to give you
a straight up vampire csection like we
was Edward and
Bella
hold up you like Twilight yeah I like
Twilight you like Twilight Twilight's my
jam you Edward take
a answer that together 3 2 1 Edward oh
are you with me are you
with me you either playing some up game
where you was straight up inside my head
yo and when you said you was going to
blow my personality after the back of my
head I'm
like that sounds like some I would say
and now there Twilight wavelength so I
guess we friends then are we best
friends now we the best of friends BFF
we are BFFs
MF when I'm with
you the world stops turning
around when I'm with you
both feet off the ground when I'm with
you trumpet start to sound when I'm with
you it's heaven when you're
around La
La no you didn't there no you
didn't great happen
Man Too Much
boy
Team
Edward
looks like another Gang Related
killing surprise a mother
prise yo yo yo what up what up what up
welcome to battle rap you we're going to
battle rap every day in the month of
February y'all yo I'm your host big
PE that's right to my left we got the
champion y'all introduced son yeah
what's happening this your boy Ryo de
I'm about to front hand back hand his
ass off my right that's right that's
right I'm all right we got the
Challenger introducing some what's up
man I'm Diller killer in the house 100
USDA a pure me no filler right here okay
okay okay yo Dill lost the toss so you
go first okay gentlemen battle rap all
right yeah man here we go you shook son
I'mma eat you for breakfast cuz I'm a
cook son I stole a Copp of field from
your girls breastes
yeah in the nipple
man you don't even know man Hey listen
man you can't even win this one your
yard dash but let me ask you a question
what do they call that a
[Applause]
mustache relax man need to relax a
little
bit take it down a little bit what the
are you
doing can you take it down a little bit
man come on what you a
horse that's the last one yo what's up
dog you know my is Rich I'm swimming in
simoleons I mean what am I supposed to
do with this miniature black
[Applause]
Napoleon hey man
[Music]
hey hey hey get
your look look at this look at that look
at that look at
that go get go get that's a boy yeah man
here we go yeah look at the chain and
his St ass
timbering sry
okay hey hey no no no no no no no hey
hey I don't know what to why are you
doing me why would you no
listen come
[Applause]
on you guys got to go
man all done man that's right man yo we
got a champion still we got a champion
still right yeah what's happening
[Music]
yeah give me the Levi Levi no you hit
give me
the Lando what oh snap yo Lando yo Lando
kissan oh hi yeah that's me dude Lando
yo yo you straight up running Cloud City
right now dog that's you man you out
there
SW well you know I I do my best Ze man Z
how do big fan big fan well Ze is real
nuts to make your acquaintance straight
up straight up man you an inspiration to
all of us man you the reason I'm out
here in Cloud City dog man I ain't
joking man but yo ideally though ideally
on an ideal situation I will be doing
like what you doing I'll be up there
like in the high chambers of cloud city
dog well see if it's nice to meet you yo
right on man cuz they got me in the the
Carbonite room right now son that's
Bullit right they got to me working with
some pig dudes and whatnot I ain't no
Pig you know and you ever notice man
there ain't a lot of brothers out here
man in space right it's like they trying
to keep us down man you know I I I don't
think that it's the policy I just think
it's really really difficult to get to
this level you've got to understand the
politics of the Empire and at the same
time all the motivations of the Rebel
all man all that all that all that all
that all that all that but ideally
though man ideally what I'm talking
about is like me and you we should like
do something together though man cuz if
you think about it yo when I was younger
man I used to fly those land Speeders
all the time my friends was like man you
should be piloting one of the x-wings
right and so that's like disappointed
man cuz I got here and they just had me
like cleaning up R2 units after the
x-wings come in Ze I got to go you
should probably man I'm saying man how
do we contact one another cuz that's the
most important thing that we contact one
another cuz yo look man ideally though
ideally though I would get to fly
somehow like the Millennium Falcon like
that would be cool and yo let me get you
my like my my I got my card in here
somewhere man I'm just trying to find
this pocket right here sometimes these
Su they don't got noet you know what Ze
just give your information to lobot here
and we'll be a touch lobot man I see how
it is I got to talk to your Mand Droid
right now man you little white ass
hair why you wearing a cake though huh
where you going the icelanded hwk
outrageous thank you and may God bless
America all right couple introductions
with the chat here this is John oor nice
to meet you John Mr Ian Roberts nice to
meet you Peter tensio all right nice to
meet you Jerome Smith come on brother
what's up
fam you know this Heath Williamson nice
to meet you Mary Woodberry nice to meet
you J Martell nice to meet you sir Tasha
Robinson come on come on come
on feel that Emily George all
right nice to meet you Daryl Stokes come
on what's up fam how you doing all right
never forget about that cuz that's all
we
got nice to meet you all right oh bring
it in bring it
in start from the bottom now we here
yeah nice to meet you all right nice to
meet you all right nice to
meet 1 18 black afternoon my Octon come
on bring it in there that I'm in there
dog I'm in there do I'm in there do you
tucking in
there I'm in there I'm in there I'm in
there all right nice to meet you man' uh
nice to meet you oh my goodness look at
this oh she is so beautiful
M I want another one there you go
precious beautiful beautiful what's her
name oh this is Livia rui okay nice to
meet you miss ruie all right come on
there he is
Boom all right manab good to meet you
here we go right this way sir email is
what I want now that's the uh you got
the most space for
attachments anyway thank you feel free
to hit me up if you remember that number
I noticed you ain't right that
down damn damn damn that girl was fly
right sh but did you see that Liam nces
movie with them wolves though the one
with them big ass wolves and Liam nces
Liam n is my oh Liam n straight jacked
up them wolves them wolves up man Sho
man hey and don't even give me start on
that one when they took his daughter
straight tuing starring Liam niss man
Liam n on the phone like I have a
certain set of
Liam don't even try and be rushing
around Liam he'll take your
arm and then oh you see the second one
though and the second one the Russians
come after him and he them all up anyway
took in two starring the incomparable
Liam n that's what what about dark man
no no huh what about Liam n is some dark
man no what about dark man when Liam's
face was changing a homie was straight
face changing
now that's just Liam n acting right
there man straight up I kid you not
Academy Award caliber classic n come on
seriously I mean like niss already need
to have a statue Li n ain't got no he
ain't got a statue he ain't got a statue
he ain't got a statue nope nope
[Music]
no the Oscar goes too Liam niss dark man
face was changing how hard is that ain't
hard do it's not hard at all damn that's
stupid mans Battleship oh
battle
ship
[Applause]
Battleship
battles Liam straight killed a robot
boat Liam niss is my
shnit but you know who I like as much as
niss as much as niss who Bruce
Willie
a Bruce Willie is my but what if they
made a movie Willam niss and Bru
Willie nces And Willie willly and nces
man
harder that would be my
[Applause]
sh
[Music]
I but I don't need you